quanti di voi scrivono con la mano
sinistra potreste alzare la mano per
favore potete usare indifferentemente la
destra o la sinistra bravi così ad
occhio e croce secondo me sarete circa
un centinaio mi dicono che in teatro si
sono circa 800 persone per cui siete
attorno al 10 15 per cento
e questa in realtà è la percentuale che
si osserva in qualsiasi sottoinsieme
dell'umanità ovunque a qualsiasi
latitudine dove ci sono esseri umani c'è
una maggioranza che predilige usare la
mano destra e una minoranza che
preferisce usare la mano sinistra
e se ci pensate una cosa strana no
perché non è metà e metà perché non 50 e
50 o non perché l'unanimità per esempio
perché non cento per cento che
preferiscono una mano destra e 100 per
cento che preferiscono la mano sinistra
io oggi prova illustrate un'idea che
cerca di spiegare perché se questa
condizione di maggioranza e minoranza
allora tutti sanno che la faccenda della
preferenza dell'uso della mano a che
fare con il cervello con il fatto che la
parte destra controlla l'arto di
sinistra e viceversa
e inoltre con il fatto che le due metà
del sistema nervoso fanno cose diverse
per esempio nella nostra specie
l'emissario sisto si occupa del
linguaggio mentre l'emisfero destro è
affaccendato con altre cose tipo di
conoscere le facce orientarsi nello
spazio e così via
quello che forse non sapete è che questi
fenomeni sono generali sono diffusi
anche in altri animali per esempio se
prendete gli scimpanzé e gli date un
tubetto con dentro del miele loro di
solito ottengono con la sinistra come
faremo noi e con la destra manipolano
per tirare fuori il miele oppure un po
più lontani da noi questi rospi li
abbiamo studiati anni fa e gli avevo
messo un pezzettino di nastro adesivo
sul muso e abbiamo visto che per toglier
seno con la zampina usano
preferenzialmente la zampa destra o
ancora alcune asimmetrie sono
addirittura più forti di quelle che
osserviamo per l'uso della mano destra e
nella nostra specie i pappagalli di
solito
usano la zampa posteriore sinistra per
tenere gli oggetti e poi in manipolano
per così dire utilizzando il lecco e lo
fanno in percentuali che sono attorno al
90 per cento quindi ancora più alte di
quelle della nostra preferenza fra l'uso
della mano destra ci sono animali che
non hanno degli arti in senso proprio
che non li usano ma comunque siccome il
fenomeno e il relativo alla
specializzazione diversa della parte
destra e sinistra noi possiamo osservare
comunque delle differenze per esempio
gli animali che hanno gli occhi
posizionati lateralmente sul capo molti
uccelli pesci rettili hanno
un'organizzazione anatomica tale per cui
quella che vedete qua quello che viene
visto dall'occhio destro viene elaborato
dall emisfero sinistro e viceversa
allora se prendete per esempio un pò
letto come questo un piccione e lo
lasciate libero di beccare una teoria di
granellini potete scoprire dopo un po
adesso il ferma il filmato verrà
accelerato perché non abbiamo tanto
tempo che la distribuzione delle beccate
non è simmetrica in realtà il pulcino
becca molto di più sul lato sinistro che
non sul lato destro perché perché
l'emisfero destro è come dire controlla
questi comportamenti visuo spaziali e
dirige l'attenzione la parte sinistra
del mondo e interessante questo fenomeno
perché in realtà lo potete osservare
anche nella nostra specie di una forma
diversa per esempio in giochetti come
questi quale che vi sembra la faccina
triste e quale la faccina allegra la
maggior parte delle persone i destrimani
perlomeno dicono che la faccina di
sinistra sembra allegra e quella di
destra sembra triste questo succede
perché noi dirigiamo l'attenzione sulla
parte sinistra del viso
e allora potete vedere che sulla parte
sinistra del viso la bocca vallin su
mentre invece sulla parte destra valli
in giù e questo per così dire colora
l'impressione dell'intera faccetta è una
fortuna che dirigiamo l'attenzione sulla
parte sinistra perché anche le emozioni
sul nostro volto vengono espresse più
intensamente sulla parte sinistra del
volto
non so se avete mai notato ma gran parte
dei ritratti in ogni epoca e con diversi
stili
i modelli tendono a mostrare il lato
sinistro del viso
questo è il famoso antonello da messina
e il sorriso dell'ignoto marinaio ma
vale anche per monnalisa le asimmetrie
che vi sto descrivendo non riguardano
solo la vista
valgono per tutti gli organi di senso
per esempio noi abbiamo studiato nei
cani l'uso della narice destra e
sinistra vedete che loro alternano l'uso
delle due narici fanno una specie di
scanning e non lo fanno a caso in realtà
e cioè con stimoli nuovi tendono usare
più la narice di destra che è connessa
direttamente l'olfatto è un senso antico
con l'emisfero destro e poi ancora in
certi casi le differenze di lato si
possono manifestare anche per organi che
non sono doppi come gli occhi le
orecchie così via ma che sono singoli
mediali per esempio la coda
allora i cani quando scodinzolano
muovono la coda sia a destra che a
sinistra ovviamente però siccome il
movimento a destra oa sinistra e
controllato dal lato opposto del sistema
nervoso
succede che se vuoi misurate l'entità
dello sco di isolamento quando per
esempio un cagnolino guarda il padrone
quindi è contento e vedete che muove la
coda un po di più a destra e tocca al
fianco destro molto di più di quanto non
tocchi quello sinistro
adesso lo stesso cane guarda un altro
cane in atteggiamento invece aggressivo
vedete che lo sco di in soli io e questo
non sorprende diminuisce ma tende anche
a spostarsi sul lato sinistro
questo succede perché mentre alle
emozioni positive sono controllate dall
emisfero sinistro che induce una
risposta di approccio di avvicinamento
quelle negative che mi fanno tornare
indietro per così dire sono controllate
dall'inizio ero destro
voi direte beh bel lavoro che fate voi
scienziati di studiare i movimenti della
coda del cane devo dire che qui ho perso
un'occasione per diventare ricco perché
una ditta americana senza dirci niente
sfruttato le nostre osservazioni e ha
inventato un piccolo marchingegno che
posto sulla coda dei cani consente di
misurare se scodinzolano un po di più a
destra oa sinistra e quindi i
proprietari possono stabilire se il loro
cane e felice oppure no non garantisco
che funzioni
allora succedono un sacco di cose
interessanti estranee non per quello che
riguarda la destra alla sinistra nel
mondo naturale degli animali quindi
quando un ranocchio vede qualche cosa di
buono è più facile che lui lo piglia con
un colpo di lingua se la vede con
l'occhio destro che non con occhio
sinistro la differenza relativa abrate
non assoluta ma c'è oppure se invece che
mangiare si tratta di aggredire un altro
con specifico per esempio questi sono
lucertole americane quando due maschi si
incontrano è più facile che si attaccano
se si vedono con l'occhio sinistro che
non con l'occhio destro e anche la
livrea cambia di colore che associata al
comportamento aggressivo più facilmente
se si vedono con l'occhio sinistro
un fenomeno generale vale per tutti
vertebrate quindi adesso quando adulti
in giro sul marciapiede con un
accompagnatore un'accompagnatrice
considerate con attenzione se la volete
tenere alla vostra destra o la vostra
sinistra a seconda di quello che vi
aspettate da lui o da lei però noterete
c'è un problema qui il problema è che
questo è un modo apparentemente molto
strano di costruire un cervello giusto
perché nel mondo gli oggetti le prede i
predatori gli altri animali hanno in
linea di principio la stessa probabilità
di apparire a destra oa sinistra per cui
in questioni che sono veramente di vita
o di morte come per esempio rispondere
un predatore una situazione in cui il
nostro ranocchio è più veloce un po più
veloce a rispondere se il predatore
arriva a sinistra che non ne a destra
sembra un modo strano per l'evoluzione
per la selezione naturale di costruire
un cervello quindi ci devono essere
state ragioni importanti ragioni per
costruire i cervelli asimmetrici quali
alcune le conosciamo ce n'è più d'una
per esempio se allo chiamo mettiamo le
funzioni da una parte risparmiamo
tessuto nervoso quindi metto il
linguaggio nell'emisfero sinistro un po
di spazio nel destro permetterci delle
altre cose come sempre in biologia il
vantaggio una questione relativa perché
succede che se mi capita di avere una
lesione l'altro emisfero non è in grado
di sostenere quella funzione ed è quello
che capita se per disgrazia
avete una lesione
alle mie sarà così sto diventate afasici
oppure considerate il caso degli animali
che qui vi parlavo prima che hanno gli
occhi posizionati lateralmente sul capo
a destra ea sinistra allora per loro si
pone il problema di come controllare
l'azione considerata ancora il nostro
ranocchio di qua vede una mosca e di qua
un'altra mosca e si trova come il famoso
asino di buridano incapace di decidere
in queste situazioni assolutamente
essenziale che una meta del cervello
assuma il controllo e dica ok si va a
destra si mangia la mosca di destra e
poi infine c'è una terza ragione
importante che è quella che ha a che
fare con la possibilità di compiere due
compiti simultaneamente visto che
parliamo di volo le galline che come
sapete sono il mio animale favorito è il
vertice della creazione dal punto di
vista cerebrale sono capaci di fare una
cosa di questo tipo e cioè di guardare
sul terreno mentre pascolano con
l'occhio destro in cerca di qualche
verne succulento e nello stesso tempo
con l'occhio sinistro di guardare in
alto emisfero destro e tenere d'occhio
l'ambiente che non compaia un qualche
predatore alato e questa cosa la possono
fare simultaneamente in maniera molto
efficiente proprio perché hanno un
cervello assimmetrico vede questo ci
dice perché ci spiega perché ci sono
cervelli asimmetrici che fanno a destra
e sinistra cose diverse ma non ci dà
ancora la risposta al problema con cui
siamo partiti all'inizio e cioè perché
una maggioranza e una minoranza
se ci pensate bene la cosa è molto
strana perché sembrerebbe più logico
avere una condizione in cui le
asimmetrie sono distribuite metà in età
considerate questo caso c'è un predatore
nel mondo e il nostro predatore a che
fare con delle prede che sono
asimmetriche metà e metà metà sono
destrimani e metà sono mancine diciamo
così allora che cosa succede succede che
il nostro predatori incontra una preda e
questa scappa a destra ne incontra
un'altra e questa scappa a sinistra e
un'altra ancora e questa scapperà non lo
so per esempio ancora a destra e così
via
ciascuna singola preda a in realtà la
sua direzione preferita però non c'è
modo per il predatore di saperlo
a meno che non ci siano incontri
ripetuti ma questo è molto improbabile
nel mare come potete immaginare quindi
questa è una situazione che fa piuttosto
bene considerati invece realtà
alternativa quella in cui le asimmetrie
sono allineate c'è una maggioranza
quindi per esempio arriva il nostro
pesciolino e questo pesciolino scappa a
sinistra poi un altro scappa a sinistra
ancora uno e scappa a sinistra e un
altro ancora che scappa a sinistra il
predatore impara sfrutta questa
regolarità e la può usare al suo proprio
vantaggio quindi allora uno dice ma
caspiterina come mai si sono evolute
asimmetria che sono simili in direzione
nella maggior parte degli individui non
era meglio allora fare metà e metà
beh la nostra idea molto semplicemente è
questa vale questo ragionamento
nell'ipotesi che i nostri organismi
siano come dire totalmente solitari cioè
posso essere libero di decidere se
essere destrimane o mancino senza
curarmi degli altri se non ho alcuna
interazione con gli altri ma nel momento
in cui c'è un qualche tipo di
interazione con altri individui
asimmetrici devo tener conto della loro
direzione di asimmetria questo nei
termini della teoria dei giochi che è
una branca della matematica si dice in
questa maniera qua quel che è meglio
fare per un individuo dipende da quello
che fa la maggior parte degli individui
del gruppo cui appartiene
allora apparentemente dovreste
aspettarvi da questo ragionamento che la
soluzione dovrebbe per l'appunto essere
quella dell'allineamento pesciolini
stanno nei banchi nel mondo e se tu ti
allontani da solo dal banco 6 pesciolino
morto in realtà no noi abbiamo provato a
fare un po di conti io con la mia
collega l'ersi rogers stefano ghirlanda
abbiamo fatto un po di matematica e quel
che abbiamo visto sorprendentemente e
che le soluzioni stabili cioè quelle che
possono reggere dal punto di vista
dell'evoluzione non sono né 50 x 50 per
cento e l'avevamo già capito ma neanche
100 per cento
le soluzioni che reggono sono quelle in
cui c'è una maggioranza e una migliore
90 10 80 20 60 40 come mai
beh lo potete capire anche senza
matematica con un semplice esempio
considerata gli sport di tipo
interattivo come per esempio la scherma
o il pugilato allora nella schermo nel
pugilato che cos'è che succede succede
che voi incontrate molti pugili che sono
destrimani è la prima volta che mi
capita di incontrare un pugile mancino
vi trovate in difficoltà perché perché i
colpi arrivano dalla parte che non vi
aspettate
ricordate cosa dice rocky balboa nel
primo film parlando di se stesso non era
un pugile mancino nessuno vuole
combattere con me ma perché nessuno
vuole combattere con i mancini perché i
mancini sono pochi perché se i mancini
fosse il numero uguale i destrimani
allora non avrebbero alcun vantaggio
questo in biologia si chiama selezione
dipendente dalla frequenza vuol dire che
il vantaggio ce l'hai
finché questi individui rimangono pochi
all'interno della popolazione e questa
la ragione per cui c'è il mancinismo e
per cui si mantiene nelle popolazioni le
nostre nonne erano molto preoccupate
quando nasceva un bambino mancino e
cercavano di correggerlo e dicevano non
devi usare alla mano del diavolo
in realtà come avrete capito il
mancinismo una condizione biologica del
tutto naturale non ha niente a che fare
con il diavolo se non per il fatto che
il diavolo sta nei dettagli e il
dettaglio in questo caso è relativo al
fatto che i mancini hanno il vantaggio
possono essere originali per così dire
perché stanno in un gruppo di
conformisti che è più grande che è
maggioritario se tra qualche migliaia
d'anni uno scienziato verrà qui ad un
ted del futuro e chiederà al suo
pubblico
quanti tra di voi come ho fatto io usano
la mano sinistra per scrivere io sono
pronto a scommettere che ne salterà
fuori una percentuale identica a quella
che abbiamo trovato oggi cioè con una
maggioranza i destrimani e una minoranza
di mancini che sono mantenuti a quel
livello fingas con pochi grazie
[Applauso]